side cross good good and the game in
2010 a tour tendon in my foot now all of
this dance and all of this on your toes
we live in a problem that I thought I'd
never had to relive again you know you
went to the doctor
What did he say you gotta let it go you
cannot do this I got a little
competition talk to me about the
decision this week we went back and
forth on the phone at the thousand times
because I really wanted to push through
I just wanted to figure it out I cannot
go and you know I have been dealing with
the pain for a few weeks and you know
once I got the MRI kind of confirmation
it was like okay reality just got real
you know and then I call my mom and she
was like you know this time you need to
follow your heart and not your head and
but it was just hard because I loved
freaking I finished things and and so
but I it's a lesson though right because
I learned something with this right the
silver lining in this is I don't find
this doctor if I never do this show you
know I've lived live like this since
2007 with a broke toe and now I can
address that and so for me man I'm
excited like I've been telling people
like I really want to do this show again
like I want to I want to season of
injuries like all the injured
celebrities there's been like Jul Nancy
O'Dell like you know what I'm telling
you there's been a lot like people had
to bow out this season alone we're on
week three and we've already had two
injuries force people out of the
competition on the other half of the
injury that I've happened like I also
same thing with me I had to get em
around on and like yeah you just like
but went on just my rotator cuff but
work I just have ten and I was
everywhere
and I know that athletes have such a
high pain tolerance so for you to have
to pull out for something like this that
means it's really serious yeah yeah I
mean look I dealt with the pain as long
as I could for two weeks but then when
it becomes sharp and start going up your
leg and see you back I'm like looking at
like and over and over and over and over
and then finally it just went oh you
missed the most honestly just like
everything else right the partnership is
always amazing but there's nothing like
the lights you know like the thing I
would remember the most by ever is that
a minute and you can't turn around now
you gotta go like what the Freak God go
and so yeah I'm gonna miss that because
that's that that's that moment to go out
and give it everything you got
heal up and that you return to us but
next week I know you'll be here because
we have very exciting news your bestie
Leah Remini is guest hosting damn gonna
get her started
you gotta give her address in some tip
I'm gonna be in her ear the whole time
really okay now say they say that you
know you can do a little bit more
cha-cha-cha